( indistinct chatter )
Let's, uh, see what people
think about you.
- Oh, my God.
- Whoa, look at this guy.
- What is this?
- What year was this?
- ( computer beeps )
- Oh.
( computer beeping )
I feel like
I'm in a hospital.
Honestly, though,
these would be cute coasters.
This is definitely
a computer.
- Yes. Right.
- 100% computer.
I've never-- is this Apple?
- This is the Apple I?
- Is this is the first Mac?
It is, in fact, the first Mac.
- Oh, ( bleep ).
- The original from 1984.
- Wow.
- I wasn't even born yet.
Same, same.
( music playing )
I'm Marques Brownlee
and I review dope new tech.
But on this show,
I'm rewinding the clock
to discover
the tech of the past
that changed
our lives forever.
This is
"Retro Tech: Macintosh."
Hey, what's up, guys?
MKBHD here,
And today we're going to
be talking about the 1984 Mac.
The original.
So this came out
nine years before I was born,
so by the time I was actually
using computers,
this thing would have been
gathering dust in my
parents' basement.
This wasn't the first ever
personal computer,
but this was the one
that changed the way we think
about what computers are
and what they can do.
It's so easy to think of Apple
as this massive company,
because they are one now.
But it wasn't always that way,
and this is one
of the computers
that helped define
what they've become today.
So, uh, let's take
a closer look in the box.
( music playing )
So, we got your user guide.
Oh, look at that.
That's how you should be
using your Mac. Just kick back.
Apple stickers.
These are probably worth a lot.
Also, the plastic has
an Apple logo on it.
Even the plastic
is Apple plastic.
It's special.
And there are two floppy disks--
"A Guided Tour of Macintosh"
and your system disk.
Don't lose that.
Something about tech
at this time
is always this color
for some reason.
I don't know why,
but that's where we're at.
Ah, this is the keyboard.
Guess what color.
1980s brown.
All right, so I'm fully ready
for the Mac at this point.
That's convenient, actually.
There's a handle
right at the top.
We can just pick up
the whole Mac just like that.
Just like-- just like
a bowling ball, basically.
That's about the weight
of a good bowling ball, too.
You know, tech demos these days
are always trying to show you
what you can do with it.
This was a very effective demo.
Oh, yeah. Come with me.
I have my computer with me.
Of course, you need to plug it
into the wall and everything,
but I like that handle.
So what do you say we, uh,
get this thing turned on?
( beeps )
( whirring )
( buzzing )
It's making noises for sure.
All right.
Screen is functional.
Mouse is functional.
It's just giving me
a question mark.
Oh, I need the system disk,
don't I?
Even in all this space,
there's no internal memory.
There's no way for it to know
how to start up without this.
This is the important piece
right here.
This is the OS.
This is the system.
That's still super-satisfying.
Would you look at that?
"Welcome to Macintosh."
Let's get into it.
( music playing )
The OG Macintosh is something
I know very little about.
In fact, I didn't even own
a Mac until 2010.
But I always see that '84 Mac
referenced as one of
the most important computers
of all time, which seems like
a pretty big deal.
So what is it about
the original 1984 Mac
that changed the game
and made way
for everything else
that followed?
- Ken, thanks for doing this.
- Yeah, my pleasure.
- Great to meet you.
- You, too.
All right.
I'm gonna start, actually,
by having you check
underneath your seat.
- Is it something--
- There's something
there for you.
- Oh.
- Oh, look at that!
And there it is, the original
Macintosh keyboard.
Just the sound of it
reminds me of being a kid.
( clacking )
I like a nice loud keyboard.
It makes me feel
like I'm doing something.
I'm working hard over here!
This is great.
This is so great.
Did the average person
in the '60s or '70s
even really know
what a computer was?
The average person had no idea
what a computer was.
Announcer:
The strange world
of the computers.
Devised by engineers...
Pre-Apple,
the computer industry
was really found
in just a handful of places--
the military,
scientific institutes.
Humphrey:
It was something
that companies did
to crunch massive amounts
of data.
The original computers, they
were very cinematic in a way.
They took up an entire room.
They had the giant reel-to-reel
tape machines on them.
They whirred and clicked
and made cool noises.
( imitating whirring )
You had guys in white lab coats
who were the only ones
who were allowed to use them.
They didn't even have screens.
Humphrey: So at that time,
IBM was the biggest computer
company in the world.
Segall: IBM-- International
Business Machines.
You couldn't have
a more cold and inhuman name.
Ackerman:
They'd been around making,
you know, calculators
and other things for decades.
They eventually started
making computers,
but they had no concept
of the home computer.
How are you gonna take
an idea like the computer,
this big room-size
intimidating machine,
and make it
a mainstream thing?
Well, the answer
is the microprocessor.
Pioneered in the early '70s,
it basically said
we can take the brain
of the computer
and shrink it down
to micro-size.
Humphrey:
So that really allows for
smaller, faster,
and much cheaper hardware.
And I think Steve Jobs
was such a visionary
that he saw where
that could go.
Steve Jobs, Steve Wozniak,
Ronald Wayne, they were
computer hobbyists in a club.
Panitz: In its early days,
Apple was a couple of guys
in a garage
just kicking around ideas and
putting together some, frankly,
pretty janky-looking
prototypes.
Humphrey: The Apple I
was their first computer,
and it literally was just
a circuit board.
Panitz:
The Apple I looks like a bad
woodshop class in high school.
And companies like HP go,
"Listen, nobody's
ever gonna want that.
Computers are for work.
They're for science.
They're not for people
in their homes."
Steve Jobs knew
they were wrong.
And from there,
he just changed the entire game.
Marques:
There were many
personal computers
that predated
the 1984 Macintosh,
but what was it that made
the Mac so unique
in comparison to
all the rest?
Since I've got a lot
of computer history
to catch up on,
I asked fellow
YouTube creator iJustine,
who's pretty much
an Apple guru,
to help me out with this.
She's reviewed just about
every Apple product
of the last decade,
and has been a devoted fan
of the brand
since she was a kid.
Today, we're at one of
the biggest tech warehouses
in Brooklyn
so she can show me
what happened
in personal computing
between the Apple II
and the 1984 Mac.
( music playing )
- I can't believe
this is a real place.
- Record players.
( gasps )
- Oh, this is-- this is--
- This-- this should have
my name on it.
This is Justine's aisle
right here.
- No way!
- I remember my fourth grade
teacher had one of these.
- You could play, like,
cards on it if you were good.
- Yeah.
I was a few years above that.
- But...
- And the mice.
They've got just about
every piece
of retro tech imaginable here,
so what better place
to check out some
of these computers
that predated
the original Mac?
This looks like all of
my latest eBay searches.
It's incredible.
I know you as a connoisseur
of all things Apple,
but there's a bunch of other
stuff that may have even
competed with the Mac here.
Yes. Starting up here,
this is the Apple II.
So this was around 1977.
This was kind of Apple's
first introduction...
- Marques: The Apple-II.
- ...into creating
the personal computer.
Now, I might need a little help,
because I can't reach it,
- but there's an on button.
- Is this it?
- Yeah, that's it.
- ( whirring )
- Whoa.
- So, obviously, it's probably
seen some better days.
- Sure. I'll give it credit
for turning on.
- It's there.
But, you know, I mean,
back then this was obviously
something that
was revolutionary
until this over here--
the RadioShack Tandy.
And it's crazy, because
this outsold the 1977 Mac
because this was $600.
Marques:
If you pop-quizzed me and said,
"Did RadioShack
ever make a computer
and did it outsell Apple's
computer at that time?",
I would have laughed.
Well, it's unfortunately true.
Marques:
It's also the only thing here
that's sort of
a space gray color.
- Yeah.
- I'm a fan of this color.
We can turn this one
on as well.
- Really?
- There we go.
I wanted to turn it
like it was a knob,
- like a TV or something.
- Like a TV.
The power button on this
and the power button on this
are already immensely better
than any computer I have now.
- Yeah.
- The power buttons
on today's computers?
- They don't live up to these.
- Then we come down here,
and this is where things
kind of get crazy.
So this is the first
introduction to a personal
computer by IBM.
This came out around 1981.
IBM was the computer company
at that time, so they're huge.
Marques:
It's got a much more
monolithic look.
And IBM was kind of late
to get into the, sort of,
personal computer...
- Right.
- ...because they were mostly
focused on business.
This wasn't something
they thought was going
to be a success.
And this is kind of
what started the huge conflict
with Mac versus PC.
- This is it?
There's notably no mouse.
- Yeah.
And what's crazy
is this is the only way
that you were able
to communicate with your
computer-- command lines.
- You had to know what to
type to make it work.
- Yeah.
It's cool,
but it's not very fun.
- Right.
- Then next, this is
the Compaq-Portable 286,
and what's nuts about this
is this was meant to be
taken places.
There's these little notches
right here, so this keyboard
actually folds up into this.
And there's
a luggage handle on the back.
Just go take a little look.
Just go look.
If you're going to call it
portable, you need a handle.
Portable? Um, I'd put that
in air quotes for sure.
It's like a suitcase.
So, the personal computer
from the mega-goliath IBM
sets, like,
waves for the industry.
And then the copycats,
they're trying to do things
like be a little cheaper
or a little more portable
or have their little gimmick
that sells them over IBM.
- This was the start
of the clones, so--
- The clone wars.
The clone wars. I mean,
it definitely happened,
and that was in sort of
this time frame before
the 1984 Mac.
- That leads us to this.
- The Mac.
- It's so beautiful.
- It's notably smaller
- than the other two by a lot.
- And it's so insane,
because everything
was stored on these disks.
So if you wanted to boot
the system, you'd have to
use the floppy disk.
And then if you wanted
to play a game, you'd
have to take that out,
put another disk in.
And then if it's like,
"Oh, hold on a second.
I need something back
from this system memory,"
- you'd have to swap 'em out.
- Yeah.
So it was such a process
because it is loading
everything into the RAM,
and you obviously don't have
a lot of it to work with.
- Not a ton of storage.
- And I always will remember,
I think I was probably
in college whenever
Apple was like,
"We are not gonna have a floppy
drive in our computers."
We're like,
"No, what do you mean?
We need that."
Apple is kind of known
for killing off ports
they don't think
we need anymore.
- Headphone jack?
- Headphone jack.
- Don't need it.
- Don't really need
that anymore.
- FireWire I think
they killed off.
- CD drive.
Marques:
CD drive, they were early
to get rid of that.
- Full size USB.
- Yep, all of it.
But, yeah,
floppy drive's another one.
Justine:
This was one of the first
computers with a mouse.
There are no arrow keys
on this keyboard.
- Oh, right.
- That was to force the user
to learn to use the mouse.
And I thought that was something
that's really interesting,
because even though
you do use a mouse,
I think those arrow keys
are pretty helpful.
This may be the first instance
of Apple killing off something
- and then bringing
it back later.
- Yes, yes.
- Okay, fair.
- So we gotta turn it on.
Okay, here we go.
I'm gonna give this to you.
Yeah. Oh, there it is.
- It's saying "no disk."
- Oh, gosh. Okay, hold on.
I gotta come around.
I gotta see this.
- "Welcome to Macintosh."
- Look at this.
Looking at this next to
the last two computers,
I mean, green text on
a black screen, mouse, UI--
- This 1984 Mac really did
change everything.
- Right.
It's what made graphical
user interface popular.
Marques:
Dragging something
to a trash can
is such an obvious
mental visual to have.
- Yeah.
- But that's one of the first
times they do that.
Yeah. I mean, this is
essentially the same setup
that we currently have now.
- It's a Mac OS.
- More or less, yeah.
I mean, you still have
that Apple menu up there.
Look at this!
Oh, man, I'm freaking out.
This is so great.
Do you want to try
typing on it?
- ( keyboard clacking )
- The sound you get, too,
is, like, kind of unique.
( clacking )
- Yeah, it's good.
- It's so great.
- They don't make 'em
like they used to.
- They don't.
Marques:
Now that I've seen
some of the Macintosh's
competitors firsthand,
I want to know
how did Apple take on
its biggest threat,
computer giant IBM?
Back then, Apple was still
the little David company
versus the Goliath.
Newscaster:
Industry analysts
predicted that Apple,
like many other
smaller companies,
would be forced out
of business.
I think Steve Jobs enjoyed
being the underdog.
I think Apple is the only thing
standing between them
and total industry dominance.
Humphrey:
So Steve Jobs and the rest
of their crew,
they knew they were going to
have to come up
with something spectacular
to put a dent in the universe.
I was the Creative Director
of Apple for,
like, 17 years altogether.
There were a number of things
about working with Steve.
First thing was he was smart.
And I mean, like, really smart.
But what really set him apart
was the marketing
side of him.
I've worked with
many big companies.
I've never met a CEO
who had that passion
and talent for marketing.
He knew that every product
had to tell a story.
Humphrey:
So Apple created a commercial.
It was in, I think,
the third quarter
of the Super Bowl,
so you had all of the eyeballs
of America on this thing.
They got Ridley Scott
of all people to direct
this commercial.
Ackerman:
It was a takeoff
on George Orwell's "1984."
Humphrey:
There was Big Brother
out there watching you,
and they sort of likened IBM
to Big Brother.
Ackerman:
And this woman comes in
running in slow motion,
swinging the hammer,
throws it against the screen
and shatters it...
( explosion )
...freeing you from the IBM,
the International Business
Machine's slog.
Announcer:
On January 24th,
Apple Computer
will introduce Macintosh.
And you'll see why 1984
won't be like "1984."
Good evening.
Marques: Soon after
that commercial aired...
I'm Steve Jobs
from Apple Computer.
We're very glad
to be here tonight.
...Steve Jobs took the stage,
ready to unveil
his latest creation
to an excited crowd
of onlookers.
Panitz:
The anticipation of what
was gonna come out,
it was like Halloween
wrapped into Christmas
wrapped into my birthday.
The original unveiling
of the first Macintosh
was once of those
Steve moments.
What I'd like to do now
is show you
the Macintosh in person.
Segall:
He was a master showman.
( cheering )
It was all so human.
Having the computer
introduce itself
was Steve's big moment to say,
"We're different."
Marques: The 1984 Mac
was different than everything
else at the time,
but it was still limited
compared to what we have now.
There wasn't much
internal storage on the Mac,
but it left room for
third party developers
to create a multitude
of software.
So I've invited a special guest
to test some of it out.
128k, people.
And K stands for...
kilobyte?
- Yes.
- Okay. Okay.
- Jeez.
- Got it.
Kids today.
Marques:
Back when I was
in elementary school,
the science teacher would roll
the TV into the classroom,
and we'd get lessons from
Bill Nye the Science Guy.
So, computers count
with binary bits.
So who better to help me learn
about the 1984 Mac
other than Bill Nye himself?
So, Bill,
I'll play a little game
that I call "Dope Or Nope."
"Dope or Nope."
Nope, nope, nope.
So, the original Mac
came with original software,
but then, of course,
several came out since then.
We're gonna go through some
of those pieces of software
and the first one's
called "Earth Plot."
- "Earth Plot."
- Okay, we pick a latitude
and longitude,
and it's gonna kind of
Google Earth-style
just make a map.
So, do you have a favorite
latitude and longitude?
Well, Los Angeles is at--
uh, may I click?
- Do I just do this?
What happened?
- I think it's just a slider.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- You knew to hold
the mouse down
- and then release on
the menu item?
- Yeah, yeah.
- When did that change?
- I don't know, man.
- Okay.
- That was deep within me.
- Yeah, you just knew.
- Whoa.
- Muscle memory.
- Yeah, it's muscle memory.
- Huh.
- You see that?
It's plotting North America.
- So you can probably
zoom back in.
- But how gorgeous.
Look at that.
This is-- this is dope.
- And it's taking more time.
- Yeah.
- This is so dope.
- I'm gonna give
the loading time a nope.
- But the final result?
- I'm saying this is dope.
You can be critical of the time,
but this is 35 years ago.
Yeah. So, you know,
they did their best, people.
- But look at that, man.
- There it is.
- That is dope.
- The full Earth.
This is definitely dope.
- This is so dope.
- I'm gonna quit and open
the next thing.
- Cool, yeah.
Earth's plotted out.
- Plotted it.
- All right, this is "Asteroid."
- Yeah, "Asteroids," plural.
- Oh, there you go.
"Asteroids."
- Yeah.
So you click it,
and then here come
the asteroids,
and you gotta, you know,
break 'em apart
so things don't go wrong.
- How do I move?
- The world's gonna end, dude!
Come on.
I didn't move at all.
Wait, I don't know
how to move my, uh...
- There you go.
You got it to rotate.
- Z and X, okay.
- Z and X are my rotation.
- ( beeps )
- Oh, you got yourself blasted.
- The physics of this
are fascinating.
- Okay. I think I can--
oh, oh, oh, oh!
- There you go.
It's just eating us alive.
There you go.
- I'm gonna spin you around
and get this one right here.
- I'm spinning around.
How about that move?
Get some of that.
Get some of that, asteroid.
With practice,
it wouldn't take two people.
- Take me down there. Yes.
- There it is.
- 2,080? Oh, killing it.
- 2,080 for just one thing.
Killing it.
I think "Asteroids" is dope,
right off the bat.
I think it's dope.
I think it's so dope.
- I got no problem
with "Asteroids."
- I'm doping up.
- That was awesome.
- So here's the floppy.
So what I have to do
to start the next one
is I have to get rid
of this floppy
and start the next one?
- Cha-chunk it.
- I have to cha-chunk it?
Do you know how to get back
to the main screen from here?
Well, you gotta eject
and it's not ejecting.
Now, what we would
have to do,
and I'm not saying--
see this hole?
- Mm-hmm.
- You would take
a bent paper clip,
push it in that hole,
and it would eject,
but that seems like
a catastrophic move,
doesn't it?
Yeah, there's gotta be a way.
So does anybody have
a paper clip?
( music playing )
So, teach a man to fish--
gently push it in this hole.
- Gently.
- ( clicks )
- Oh, I had to go-- okay,
all right, all right.
- There you go.
But still, that was
a catastrophic failure.
I think we want to cycle
the power off.
- Off.
- And then let that CRT,
that cathode ray tube
shut itself down.
Let the electronics drain.
- Drain, man.
- ( Marques chuckles )
- ( beeps )
- Three, two.
- Look how happy he or she is.
- That is adorable.
It's adorbs.
Totally adorbs.
Marques:
Okay, the last one
is "Mac Surgeon."
All right, "Mac Surgeon."
What do you want? Body parts?
And here we go.
"Mr. Thomas Jones,
a 65-year-old-man with a history
of heart problems,
came in with problems
of lower back pain.
You thought he felt
a pulsating mass in the abdomen.
You ordered X-rays of the
abdomen. They showed nothing."
- I think we gotta order
an ultrasonic.
- That's the spine?
- We're learning as we go.
- Please insert
the disk "Others."
- This was how we rolled, man.
- Oh, my goodness.
It was not the good old days.
It was the old days.
- Let's operate.
- Let's operate. Sure.
- He's got a tear.
- Let's make an incision.
- Where? Right about here?
- Yeah, right up the center.
- Oh. There you go.
- There it goes. Went around
the belly button.
Pressure's now a hundred--
then what are we doing?
Marques: How realistic is--
are we sewing this back up?
I guess so.
I'm really not sure
what we're doing.
Ooh, this one.
This is a needle and thread.
Okay.
His blood pressure's dropping.
- He'll be fine.
- Well, okay. You may be right.
- Marques: What?
- He's bleeding like crazy, man.
- Uh, maybe he's not
doing so good.
- ( flatline )
"I'm sorry, doctor.
The patient's heart
has stopped."
You say that like
that's a big deal.
- Um, we could play again?
- Well...
- But it's quite troubling.
- So where are you at
on this one?
- I think this has
potential for dope.
- On the nope or dope scale?
But I'd have to spend
a lot more time.
This seems like one
that has a bit of
a higher learning curve.
Yes. Higher learning curve.
- Yeah. I'm gonna
give this a nope.
- Yes!
So, I appreciate you helping out
with the Dope Or Nope segment.
I'm learning a lot
about the original Mac.
- This has been a lot of fun.
Appreciate it.
- Let's change the world.
Marques:
Steve Jobs knew that in order
to differentiate the Macintosh
from its competitors,
he'd need to get it
on the radar
of both the tech crowd
and the "it" crowd.
Humphrey:
Steve Jobs really did
a great job
of getting Macintosh into
the hands of influencers.
He gifted it
to John Lennon's son Sean.
And then Andy Warhol
got his hands on one,
and actually ended up
using it in one of his
art installations.
Steve Jobs created that buzz
because if
the cool people like it,
then, of course,
everybody's gonna like it.
Ackerman:
The Macintosh really conquered
the popular conception
of what a computer should be.
And they said,
"We're gonna make sure
you have the software tools
that you need most
so you're gonna buy
our machine."
Here's MacWrite.
Here's MacPaint.
When MacPaint came out,
it allowed creatives
to make what they do
orders of magnitude easier.
So you really only need
your own creativity,
and it's absolutely
a straight line to Photoshop.
It all started with MacPaint.
( music playing )
Marques:
Some artists,
like Pinot Ichwandardi,
are still using
MacPaint today.
Many of his works
have gone viral,
like his animation
of Donald Glover's
"This is America."
( music playing )
Wow.
It's the Brooklyn Bridge,
but represented with a super,
super detailed, like,
individual pixels.
Yeah...
Marques:
Whoa.
Yeah.
Wow, that's crazy.
Why continue to use
this computer
versus all
the crazy modern stuff
we have available now?
I'm a terrible artist.
We'll try it,
we'll try it.
( music playing )
Everything they do
is gonna be new to people
at this time.
- Yeah.
- So everything they do is sort
of revolutionary in a way.
Let me put the finishing
touches on this.
I mean, I drew a whole tree,
and you can--
can you tell it's a tree?
I appreciate how generous
you're being about my drawing.
- ( laughing )
- I sent you a video
not too long ago...
- Mm-hmm.
- ...with a little bit
of movement in it.
This is that video.
And you had some time to make
an animated version of it,
- which I'm super excited
to possibly see.
- Yeah.
Marques:
And it would kind of be
the first animation software
anyone could get
their hands on...
- Yeah.
- ...as far as personal
hobbyist animation.
Yeah, yeah.
Look at that.
That's so good.
- ( laughter )
- Yeah.
Wait, I gotta look back
at the video now.
Yeah. The amount of pixels
being held next to each other.
Yeah, thank you.
( music playing )
Even if the 1984 Mac
wasn't your childhood computer,
we've all been impacted
by Apple's innovation
over the last three decades.
The legacy of the Macintosh
is the fact that
Steve Jobs was able to put
a computer in all of our homes.
Bill Nye:
They literally flipped
the chart at Apple.
"We're gonna make the user
the main person here."
- It's just a cool idea.
- It changed the computer from
being an industrial tool
to something that is like
a pair of eyeglasses.
Something that's useful,
but very personal,
and you make that choice
based on how you feel
it reflects you outward
as well as inward.
Panitz:
The Macintosh computer
not only changed the way
we use computers,
but also has pigeonholed
the computer industry
into just doing what they do.
It was the human
technology company,
and it was about pushing
the human race forward,
and Steve did
an amazingly good job
of pushing
the human race forward.
Marques:
Computers are everywhere,
and while we kind of have
this whole
new generation growing up
who only really know computing
as touching
and swiping on a screen,
there is a gigantic chunk
of humanity
that knows computers
as a mouse,
a keyboard, a screen,
and an OS.
And that is thanks
in major part to the 1984 Mac
and the vision behind it.
It's pretty incredible.
Thanks for watching.
Catch you guys on the next one.
Peace.